every bari puccio con zac non è così
bello però mettere le mani sul mio corpo
mi sento violato con grazia partitica sì
volevo dirvi ho fatto due vittorie su e
inpex lei gen
apex legend e direi pecs non si capisce
come mai però vabbè ho fatto due
vittorie con tom pietro vi lascio al
video lescure non fosse marchi viaggio
giallista limiti io a te come si fa a
lato una mina raggiungermi e va bene
così giochiamo così perché coi a nessuno
tra le parti di pietro partiamo partiamo
partiamo non fa pronto allora aggiunge
con il petrolio non voglio ti voglio
come amico bastavano voglio bravissima
sa blocca utente blocco utente potente
basta basta elenco di blocco basta ma
come giochiamo al suo gioco come perché
hakodate preso queste mi chiama e ceo vj
fa vinciamo non ha valore del giornale
parte no allora io qua si può dare il
jump nasser quindi la cosa bella è
questa io spero che nel prossimo battero
gli alimentino quello dove c'è uno c'è
anche lo shooting che spara lui e tu non
fai niente io guardo le partite di vento
il numero uno e linz 22 in italia perché
numero uno e tom paga uno spitfire che
sputa fuoco duro speciale ruolo ma c'è
anche sul mercato viola attenzione
anch'io ho il turbocompressore è legge
ma il turbocompressore leggendario tra
l'asse perché è solo ma che cos'è ti fa
stare molto più in fretta col devotion
tappa i buchi parla di ritrovarlo
default preferisco molto di più collare
d'oro di server o no tra quello che è un
problema di tutto questo mica mi sono
svegliato 20 minuti fa è tutto così è
troppo per me ma pietro e mezzogiorno e
mezza troppo lorenzo giorno quarto ti
sei svegliato a mezzogiorno no alleviare
un mezzo
mamma mia cosa fai la notte viene da
lavora lavora siamo quasi in safe otto
squadre rimaste il sogno prosegue non
abbia fatto nulla quindi va bene passi
non ne vedi proprio l'ora di vederli per
vedere i passi dopo attivare qualcosa no
no no
non ne vedo proprio no non ne vedo senza
spari sopra possiamo darli a prendere se
vuole eccoli eccoli che sono ancora
sotto sono fra un po più a nord poi
centro sinistra manco si sono contesi
eccoli colpito 11 da dietro non è la è
un altro lunghissimo con l'amore il tuo
e mancano solo
ecco le dà valore sostiene in sotto il
mio amico colpito colpito di prenderla
dietro dietro a dietro la dietro vieni
eccomi sono con taylor e tra un secondo
flight
amori stesi giuro stavano a guardare non
voglio rubarla grazie tommy non solo
abbiamo un so come 150 solo non volevo
rubarla
grazie grazie grazie mille hai fatto un
po di fatica erano attenzione granata
qua da me e lui allora io io su vieni
qua e mi sto pagando addosso la dieta
e lì ragazzi arrivo loro vada aggressiva
aggressivo con la multi si fuori uno qua
preso
buono morto mancanti ma abbiamo vinto
solo in due gli ultimi siamo 3 contro 2
va per la vittoria va bene per i vari
goup eccoli giocate livelli venire
colpito hanno richiamato forse l'amico
lia e qui attenti alla trappola dentro a
non entrare per forza
facciamo una pagina e da dissi
moltissimo è andato giù
ne manca uno e poi papa ed entra in 3
entro lo fai troppa esito omega
signori bella partita mi è piaciuta dai
è stato molto figo la differenza di
danno tra noi e tom non ha fatto questo
ogni volta che vinci devi fare questo
non ho fatto questo mi scusate vincent i
ragazzi noti
voglio la vittoria tattico proprio poi
ci siamo carichi tattici facciamo le
cose giuste voi la vittoria mi sono
schiacciato sul muro ma vabbè io
onestamente spero che rimanga così chi
mi piace tantissimo anche molto più di
forte posto forme facendoci finendo è
sceso verso est on earth hour precedente
il caricatissimo è luis molti follia
da uno che il nuovissimo
ok pulite mandato giù porti tutti morta
il pezzo perfetto grande ragazzi bravi
molto bello a star ma comunque beni
qualora dato che grazie grazie grazie
grazie
madonna sono sono abbastanza vicini
pizzi dei ragazzi dove vedere un secondo
ma non ama vedere amici
eccoci 1 quarda io non li ho sparato per
non pesare ma di euro contro l'altro non
sparare a piedi ma cosa non hai capito
di non sparare massima con il problema
che va bene va bene una sporca circa 900
che ho altri bocciato con o lo vuol
provare scendi giù nel mercato prova a
vedere nel mercato è comprata la crime
hai comprato il cra qce al mercatino
della flight scarola cracks spaghetti
stop in grando gente io pino gente voi
sapete dove sono spariamo speriamo con
la guerra rivara rivara rivara e passano
larghi primi dobbiamo prendere il
premier guarda sei tu che io io seguo le
dici vabbè insieme lo speriamo
e spuntano in faccia tra due secondi
ecco mi ha sparato dietro in arrivo vedo
najo lantern e lachlan perché la e lo
siamo anche pucciare granata è la tua
pietro con la multa no no no no aprite
in casa allora allora una granata ok
oppure se lontani dai missione che vi
ammazzo parole dubbio
no no non curati pure errore è finita
possiamo sta arrivando un reti in casa
vorrei che in casa si sente più dolore e
dentro di ritorno dove arrivo sono qua
[Applauso]
pagano cielo
1 down lanciare l'opa da me sono
entrambi senza armatura va e diamo tre
due uno ha dentro tra regione giu
ragione fuga uno solo
mancava solo la cta lucidiamo recitiamo
lì non so se sia la mater guarda cosa
accadde l'ho spaccato non pagate
no uscire dall eccidio cilea mia mente
no il primo che abbiamo bloccato le con
lo scudo d'oro non ci credo cazzarola è
ancora vivo in cura siamo lavoro 1 e
dove riuscivo a curarla spetta poi ai
savoia arifaj ice chiederà che il finale
per una volta 50 capi da riesco a
vederla perché dietro il camion marimi
davanti ogni volta o dietro cavino
dietro una porta bravi bravi grazie maio
sempre stesse chi facciamo pietro
signori questa è la prima della vita non
è una prima la seconda la terza vittoria
in generale di apex 6 gen spero vi sia
piaciuto il video è quasi un commento e
mi piace anche perché ha cominciato da
descrizione se non sapersi iscrivetevi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo io da
ragazzi
[Musica]